[Music]
in 1995 shania's life changed seemingly
overnight with the release of her
sophomore album The Woman in me hi at
this is Shania Twain here 28 years ago
the budding Superstar invited us into
her world I'm just signing autographs I
get the most thrill out of making the
music that's the most fun and exciting
part
[Music]
recording in a studio was new to Shania
but she had always been a performer
foreign
Twain in Timmins Ontario Shania started
playing gigs at just eight years old and
as one of five children in a home where
money was scarce she wanted to earn as
much as possible to help pay the bills
if I had to get new guitar strings
that meant you know maybe we didn't get
milk you know it really meant that you
know it was very it was really touch and
go for a long time when we were kids and
so you know when we they had to make a
lot of sacrifices
[Music]
sacrifices paid off the girl who changed
her name to Shania was on her way what
did you do with that first paycheck
definitely went to Food
um a lot of fries no no I never bought
fries for my own home food
um I've always enjoyed cooking
so it would have been more rice or you
know certainly stale items always sale
items that when I finally made enough
money to not to stop collecting coupons
and and going only to the sale items I
was to me that was absolute luxury I was
rich you know in my mind I wasn't
printing
moment but in my mind I'm like ah
no more bruised apples in 1996 Shania
took home her first of five Grammys I am
totally overwhelmed I'm calling you from
the Grammys you don't already know
um I got the Grammy for uh best country
album I've never had so much attention
in my whole life and I'm loving every
minute of it the woman in me come on
over and up soared to the top of the
charts making Shania the only female
artist to have three consecutive
certified diamond albums
[Applause]
but years later the top-selling female
country artists of all time would be
singing a different tune
in 2008 she separated from her husband
and longtime collaborator mutt Lang
after he had an affair with her close
friend
[Music]
the stress along with what was later
diagnosed as Lyme disease affected her
singing I was slowly losing my voice
yeah
and
that was a physical uh result or effect
of not
you know expressing myself and
restricting myself and the more famous I
got the more I restricted myself but
that's manifested itself and that's got
to stop because you know I'm very
unhappy not having my voice
[Applause]
let's go girls regaining control of her
voice and personal life remarrying in
2011 Shania set her sights on making
more music
now she's ready for a new chapter with
her sixth studio album queen of me